baby Yoda doo doo doo doo - Doo - baby
Oh duh doo doo doo doo doo doo - baby
Eau de doo doo doo doo - Doo - baby Oda
grandpa yo da doo doo doo doo doo doo
Grampy Eau de doo doo doo doo doo the
crab Theo de doo doo doo doo - Doo
grandpa Yoda Darth Vader doo doo doo doo
- Doo the Darth Vader doo doo doo doo -
Doo the Darth Vader dududududududud are
later for stop joking joking doo doo doo
doo doo the force joking joking I always
hated that song
[Music]
hello Internet
welcome to film theory the show that
takes the Internet's most adorable meme
obsession and then turns it into cold
hard emotionless learning as much as
well bad mouth the empire heading up an
intergalactic government it's gotta be a
hard job set the retirement age to 55
and you only gets to retire before he
can barely string a sentence together
backwards do not there is no try
but if you set the retirement age to
like I don't know 550 Han Solo's never
gonna see his pension don't wonder there
was a rebellion against these guys now
in case you aren't hip with the kids
lately or didn't trample your loved ones
in your rush to sign up for Disney Plus
I'm talking about baby Yoda the tiny
cuddly wobbly Bubba kins of the new
Disney Plus show the mandalorian the
baby version of a member of Yoda's
species who is in one episode already
the most endearing character in this
franchise move aside Korg's get the boot
Ewoks baby Yoda filled the void that you
never could baby Yoda is like cute
ception but the kicker is that by our
standards he's not even a baby the
mandalorian depicts him as a 50 year old
toddler their age that's all you can get
me yes 50 years old my star wars'
standards that would make baby Yoda part
of the Silent Generation by that I mean
the one that came before the baby
boomers which of course in Star Wars
where all the babies that were born
right after Alderaan went boom okay
boomers there's one less planet in the
galaxy listen this topic it's really
close to home for me because I currently
own a toddler you'll hear parents saying
stuff like I wish they could stay little
forever but half a century of diaper
changes is something no one is signing
up for but all those diapers and memes
got me thinking fifty years is a really
long time to be a baby a relatively
helpless baby and I'm saying that as a
human the species with the longest
adolescence on the planet so how does
this insanely long childhood happen and
is there any way that 50 years of tummy
time could be remotely plausible
scientifically well I started
researching as I do and it turns out
that it's not just scientific precedent
but an explanation here for almost
everything that we know about the entire
Yoda species that's right understanding
the biology of baby Yoda isn't just a
fun fact from the mandalorian or me
overthinking a sci-fi franchise but it's
the single key to understanding the most
beloved character in Star Wars history
and why he Yoda by the time we get to
the main series of movies is pretty much
the only one of his species left to say
between this theory and the last one I
did over on game theory about Star Wars
this force being pretty much
scientifically accurate which if you
haven't watched you absolutely should
after this episode starting to think
that George Lucas might secretly be a
scientific genius almost let's not give
him too much credit so join me as I take
a look into the evolutionary biology of
baby Yoda and finally figure out why
they're so cool and also why they're
practically extinct before we open your
biology textbooks to chapter 5 we need
to clear the air on one thing no I don't
know the actual name of the species Yoda
comes from but you know what I'm in good
company because George Lucas didn't
either
George Lucas specifically didn't want
Yoda species to have a name and rarely
sanctioned work that revealed
information about their Lord so even
though the Yoda species existed in
places like Knights of the Old Republic
the video game information about them
doesn't appear in anything that's
officially canon anymore so instead of
spending this entire episode saying the
word Yoda and having to clarify between
whether I'm talking about Yoda the
species or Yoda the individual member of
that species
I'll instead be referring to the Yoda
species as the Tri dactyls
because their extremities have three
digits right but bear in mind that's
really just a fan-made designation for
all the members of the Yoda species that
were currently aware of which are just
three honestly you got original Yoda you
got rattled from the Phantom Menace who
just appears for a couple seconds and
baby Yoda whatever his name ends up
being from the Mandalorian so with that
bit of housekeeping out of the way and
with the very short list of actual known
members of the Yoda species what do we
know about try dactyls we know that Yoda
lived to the ripe old age of 900 in
Return of the Jedi which everyone else
is surprised about but he isn't seeming
to indicate that it's not really that
big of a deal for him baby Yoda who's
just stuck with that name for this
episode I guess is 50 but functionally
he's about a 10 months old if my kid is
any indication he's nonverbal but he is
capable of walking and getting into
trouble
so we know
as a tri dactyl you get 900 years in the
galaxy on the high end but at least the
first 50 of them are spent as a baby
which I guess leaves like a hundred to
make it through high school another 200
years of living in your parents basement
before finally getting your own
apartment at the tender age of 300 now
because we're working in outer space and
in a fictional franchise it's worth
double-checking when they say that baby
Yoda is 50 years old in the Mandalorian
does that translate to years as we
understand them here on earth and it
appears like it does according to
Wikipedia the Republic's standardized
it's time based on Coruscant which
conveniently rotates its son exactly
once every 365 course auntie in days
which are broken down themselves into
24-hour increments and then minutes that
are incredibly close to our own minutes
so when Yoda says that he's 900 years
old it's pretty close to what we think
nine hundred years is and the
Mandalorian has every reason to be
surprised that his 50 year old mark was
still a baby
so knowing that it's time to talk about
the biology having such a long
development period is more than just an
interesting evolutionary quirk it
actually tells us a lot about how try
dactyls may have evolved over time
mostly because it parallels a lot of our
own human evolution you see most animals
evolved to shorten the amount of time
between birth and reproductive maturity
so that they can go on and grow their
population as fast as possible but
that's not the only successful
evolutionary strategy you may have
noticed that us humans have incredibly
long and particularly vulnerable
childhoods when a baby giraffe is born
it can stand almost almost almost right
away humans on the other hand not so
much it is taking months if not a year
for a baby human to actually get up on
its feet
so why do humans the smartest animals on
the planet come out so useless well it
turns out that the whole issue comes
down to our brains you see our brainy
heads and the fact that they're so fat
have changed our entire course of human
evolution our ancestors who many believe
emerged from sub-saharan Africa we're
among the first species of animals to
stop walking around on four legs and
start walking up on to our brains were
big enough that we were able to logic
out the idea that it took less energy to
walk on
and it minimized our bald skins exposure
to the extremely hot ground temperatures
in those African deserts as newly
bipedal people our evolution started
favoring other members of our species
who could also walk upright good for us
natural selection at its finest but
there's always a price to pay for
innovation you see as we evolved to be
more and more capable of walking and
running around on two legs our bodies
evolved to facilitate that and
compensate for our changed center of
gravity primarily doing this by
narrowing our hips this in turn helped
us to walk upright like champs and all
of a sudden we had a problem that big
fat head of ours was literally too big
to be born sure we had ourselves a big
brain but now there was nowhere for it
to go because our hips were too narrow
to accommodate birthing ahead that huge
so human evolution had to change again
as the theory goes we started having
babies earlier in their gestational
period earlier at a time when the baby
was still tiny and smushy and helpless
which would be pretty darn bad for our
survival except for one thing the heads
were still small enough to squeeze up on
out of there still a very painful
process but now at least it was doable
and then once the baby was on the other
end there would be what's known as the
fourth trimester an extra trimester of
development that happens outside in the
real world where we as parents would
have to take care of that helpless
newborn because technically it still
should have been developing in the womb
it just needed to be you know evicted
from its home before it was too big to
leave its door now let's take a look at
her friendly Yoda what features do we
see well he's bipedal he's small with a
disproportionately huge head for his
highly evolved brain he's got a short
highly efficient body with diminutive
narrow features including his hips even
looking at the basic character model you
can see how in order to procreate the
Tri dactyls would have to have
themselves of radically different
proportions you can also see how having
a big brain is a huge evolutionary
advantage humans are so far at the top
of the food chain that we protect other
members of the food chain
try dactyls in the Star Wars universe
are the wisest and most powerful force
users in the galaxy but the downside is
that they like us are essentially born
too early helpless for months if not
years or until at least their dad makes
them pay rent and their mom stops doing
their laundry this theory continues to
hold water if we look at infancy for
humans versus infancy for try dactyls in
their first two years human baby brains
grow to 75% of their full adult size we
don't know if this is the same for troit
actuals but we do know that the
proportions of human babies paralleled
the proportions of baby Yoda enormous
head adorably tiny body besides making
babies hilariously top-heavy these
proportions also serve a function in
infancy human brains command up to
eighty seven percent of the total energy
that the body uses at rest meaning that
even while sleeping the body is
diverting a massive amount of energy to
growing the brain because of this the
rest of the baby's growth lags behind
the head where the brain is this
according to the expensive tissue
hypothesis we can see that baby Yoda is
an extreme version of this principle
with a wildly huge and merchandize Abul
head and a teeny tiny body making me
think that baby Yoda is an extremely
evolved version of what the human race
could look like someday the process of
evolutionarily elongating the
development period is called NeoTV
and after humans benefited from it
surviving when our relatives didn't well
evolution didn't stop its roll humans
are actually still experiencing longer
development periods now than we even did
10,000 years ago the shape of our faces
and heads are continually becoming less
like our Neanderthal cousins by becoming
flatter less hairy less oblong again we
share a lot of these same features with
Yoda whose small flat faced with an
enormous head but if human evolution
continues to make our childhoods longer
and longer the question of course
becomes where does it stop well it stops
at Yoda the problem with a long
childhood is that a lot can happen when
you're tiny and helpless eventually
there's an evolutionary tipping point
where childhood becomes so long that it
actually leaves the species too
vulnerable to survive into adulthood try
dactyls could very well be the extreme
end point of a species like ours as the
Mandalorian clearly shows baby try
dactyls even 50 year old baby try
dactyls aren't capable of taking care of
themselves sure they have impressive
force powers but very little control
over them
human children similarly are pretty darn
helpless and it means that we have to do
things like baby-proof the house and
make up all kinds of safety rules for
kids
imagine having to worry about that sort
of stuff for 50 or even a hundred years
it becomes extremely hard for the
species to get their offspring to a
place of self-sufficiency and that's
just the tip of the iceberg natural
disasters plagues drone attacks from the
Empire all of those things are gonna be
pretty darn hard to avoid but they
become a lot easier to bounce back from
if suddenly your species can repopulate
quickly but if all of a sudden you're
spending a hundred years or more to
reproduce a single generation I mean
you're just begging for the next Death
Star to give you a little zap which
brings us to yoga we know so little
about his history but what we're able to
theorize is pretty darn incredible
he's practically the last of his species
because of the evolutionary double-edged
sword that he's dealing with on one hand
he's one of the most highly evolved
beings in the galaxy
but he's so evolved that his species can
no longer survive they're completely
obscure it's incredibly tragic and no we
don't have any of the details about how
the Tri dactyls were wiped out but that
elongated childhood that extended
neoteny to the extremes of 50 plus years
of childhood that is certainly a massive
contributor as to why so incredibly Star
Wars the series often derided as being
space fantasy and not science fiction
turns out to be scientifically plausible
yet again so gotta hand it to you Lucas
I'm pretty stunned no I've tried to help
you out with this and the whole
midi-chlorians powering the force thing
but I gotta admit still have some
quibbles to level at you about the
Jedi's recruitment practices now it'll
be coming up pretty soon we have some
bones to pick on that front okay friend
in the meantime if you didn't see the
real-life equivalent of midi-chlorians
and how they're actually powering the
real life force in your day to day life
click the video that you see on screen
right now that'll take you to my other
science of star wars episode over on
game theory looking at midi-chlorians
mitochondria and how we're all just a
little bit Jedi in the meantime remember
that's just a theory a film theory and
cuts
[Music]